ce problème que nous avons là-dedans
moment dans le sanctuaire est un problème qui
est présent dans tous les pays
producteurs de café du monde
prix des différents cafés que
les pays produisent à des niveaux
extrêmement bas qui n'atteignent pas
couvrir les coûts de production
[Musique]
Je suis très excité de continuer
la ferme ce que mon père et mon grand-père déjà
mais alors la vérité
Si la crise continue ainsi, je ne le pense pas.
Je vais devoir chercher d'autres possibilités et
jusqu'à ce que j'aille aux USA
[Musique]
J'ai eu 100 000 bâtonnets de viande
arbres cadavres en Grande-Bretagne pour
je l'ai mis pour produire du panela et ce n'est pas le cas
je regrette
jamais
tous les personnages et ça m'a rendu triste
[Musique]